[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a lad well today guys i'm
honored to have another absolute lad on
the podcast for you and today's guest
probably has one of the more eventful
careers out of the lot he started off
his career in the nrl with the melbourne
storm before heading over to the super
league in england where he played for
the london broncos and castleford he
then changed codes to play rugby union
with the sales sharks where he instantly
made an impact playing for the england
international side almost straight away
and now he's about to do the opposite of
to what most kiwis do and he's moving
back to new zealand at the back end of
his career to give it a crack here and
although i don't know him well
i do know he is an absolute lad it is
one of the greats danny solomona welcome
brother
ah cheering my bro what an intro what a
bloody intro love it
mate what a career like i can't can't
believe how much stuff you've got
through you're only 28 you're only just
getting started and you've achieved all
that already
oh mate to be fair like i was only
probably looking back on it a couple of
days ago maybe a week ago
yeah and you know you know people get
caught up all up in like the future
about what's going to happen
but no one really reflects on like um
just your life in general where you've
come from
and to do that and to get a bit of
advice to do that for myself because i
was like stressing like mad
you know it's not easy moving from town
to town let alone from a full country
over to half across the world
back to your hometown
you know moving you know when i first
came here i only came with a suitcase
thinking i was going back and months
later
but you know
five years six years went by and you
know i've got my own little family
um yeah everybody it's it's mad it's
madness
and what's inspired this latest move
back to new zealand
um to be fair the main one was just to
like get back to my my grandparents my
grandparents are not getting any younger
um yeah i feel like i've missed a lot of
family time especially like crucial
moments like my little nephews and
nieces
you know five-year-old birthdays
you know just just little things like
that i feel like i've missed a lot
and you know i had to sacrifice a lot
for
for rugby and generally is it's
generally my family time that i had to
sacrifice for my rugby
and any other rugby you know rugby
player or any sportsman out there
that has a career a lot you know
they know what sacrifices are you know
i'm sure you do too so like
it
unfortunately was my family that i had
to sacrifice a lot
and you know this time now i'm putting
them first and i'm coming back home and
just to try and spend some some quality
time with them and then obviously get
stuck into
to super rugby npc
um just just to play some expansive
rugby some exciting rugby just to
hopefully pick up the uh the old legs um
just just to keep up for the old young
lads out there
mate that's a really exciting thought
you playing super rugby mate it's gonna
suit you down to the t have you got have
you got anywhere with contracts or
anything are you still looking
no it's because obviously everyone's
like fully booked in it like basically
miq miq style just gonna go in there
just see see if i'm lucky
and then i just try crack a gig
somewhere i'm not too bothered mate if
i'm honest i'm just
just going in with an open mind um
obviously they play a way different um
play style to to england as well
so it'll just be
going in there probably spending a day
or two with a couple of teams seeing how
they are understand their philosophies
and probably get to know some of the
boys and
probably make the decision after that
but no nothing too solid bro to be fair
so when are you available have you
finished up at sale now and you're
available to move back to when do you
actually make your move oh mate i've
been finished for a while um yeah so
me and cell you know we we ended on on
pretty good terms um
so
i've just been waiting it's that mrq
again i think every
like every resident or citizen of new
zealand will understand trying to get
back there
may it is crazy trying to get an miq
space
and then obviously like my flights like
so i i was stupid
i booked my flights first and then i
tried to book miq later so i was just
like oh
what a nightmare
and then obviously trying to sort out
like my partner my daughter's visas
so i did everything backwards like an
absolute sparse
so you said you ended up with sale uh on
a good note was that at the end of your
contract or did you manage to get out of
your contract because i know you're a
legend over there at sale
yeah to be fair obviously like you know
i think you know new coach came in um
you know philosophy changed
you know although i was i was keen i was
dead in it but i think
it was just that you know gravity was
just pulling me different direction and
um
and i was getting him back in good form
i had you know his first year he come in
alex he um
i wasn't in the best of you know best of
mental states and and and you know form
as well
and you know i was ready to hang up the
boots then and there but
you know i i thought i was like no man
like i'll you know i'd kick myself if i
didn't give it a rare hot crack if you
know for another year and if obviously
if i still feel the exact same way
about rugby itself then you know then
i'll call it a day but
so i ended up just having a red dot
crack and then you know coming back into
form and then just still something
wasn't feeling right so i was just like
oh look so i sat down with um with all
in the cut and the club
and then they're very understanding they
said yeah look if you miss your family
that much if you miss your home that
much we're not going to stand in the way
and obviously they've got
you know exciting young young players
there now um so
they're in good hands when when i left i
didn't leave him and you know with no
wingers at all and obviously they've got
a lot of experience there as well so you
know
uh yeah so it was pretty good it was
pretty good timing to part to be fair
because then now i can get back home
because i'll get back in like i think
feb the 15th i get out
out of miq
and um and i think the first i think
it's first game is the 18th i think it
is on feb i think so
perfect miss pre-season straight in
there
no i doubt it bro all these guys just
chomping at the bits to get me in their
pre-season camps mate
[Laughter]
but you you
home is auckland for your way so is that
ideally where you want to be with the
blues or moana pacifica or would you
even go back to the warriors with the
league
and anyway because they're not in
auckland i was speaking to uh ben
murdock i was just just chatting to him
about obviously life and how i'm coming
back home
yeah but now yeah ideally i think uh
back to auckland
um i'm not gonna say who yes i'm just
i'm just ideally auckland i'd like to
you know be around my family like i said
that's my number one priority at the
minute it's just being around my family
you know if i can be in auckland that'll
be you know that'll be a bonus
so
yeah so if a team like the crusaders or
someone were the ones to come knocking
would you sign with them or ideally
you'd be looking to stay in that
auckland region
oh mate like
that that's a tough one and it's like
saying do you want to come back to like
the best new zealand rugby team in
history you know i realized crusaders
has got a like a massive history like
every every club does
and that's like that's the hardest thing
and that's probably why i'm so excited
about this any club i go to at the
minute
the history and the you know everything
behind that club and the franchise
itself
it's just mental
and like you know i do i get excited
when i sign for sale because you know it
was exact same year but
just thinking about obviously back home
how you used to watch like all the other
like dudes growing up all the ex-all
blacks growing up you know they're all
crusaders um hurricanes blues
so
that's that's what's exciting at the
moment
made exciting times exciting times for
new zealand fans but anyway before you
get too far pretty keen to hear about
what your life was like growing up and i
know you're brought up in auckland so um
give us the rundown for you
oh
wait what's not to tell uh
right yeah a little south auckland kid
growing up in hotaro obviously went to
you know public schools
getting up to
like up to no good
at every chance i could
um
my mom and dad were pretty like um
they knew straight away i wasn't keen on
school anyway i only went to eat my
lunch play some rugby
uh you know i used to nick a few bikes
here and there
oh yeah
i was a little i was i was a little uh
what can you swear on this bro yeah if
yeah sure you can oh no i was just a
little devious child hey
just i was just up to no good i'm not
like i didn't want any other way i just
wanted to be naughty i just want to
want to play rugby eat my lunch be with
my mates but you know growing up in
south auckland was the eastern grown up
if i don't feel like if it wasn't for
growing up in south auckland and the
hardships that came with it
wouldn't have
given me what i have now
i think it was the resilience obviously
of um just keep going
you know no matter what you had or what
you what you're going to do
it's about the the outcome that's that
eventually is going to happen and
whether it's positive or negative you
just got you got another option but to
keep going
and i feel like that's probably what
like south auckland's given me
and probably like
life in general as well
and you were a gun at ragbia from a very
young age i've heard lots of stories
about how good you were as a young kid
when did you know that you were a gifted
rugby player
oh
it's
me i i think it was just
trying to like enjoy it really i didn't
really buy too much into like oh may
you're so good you're so good
i just loved i just loved loving rugby i
think everything about rugby playing
like from when i was five playing with
my older brothers you know because my
dad had to coach it
and it was another way for my from my
dad to coach me he was like you either
come up two grades or you stay down
there and you get coached by someone
else i was like nah stuff that i you
know i'll come play i'll come play with
my brothers
and i'll and i'll get coached by you
and then so it just happened from there
so like obviously when six year old
seven eight
nine ten so then i ended up playing with
my brother and his mates and you know
all of them were just like i it just was
just
like bread into me just like any other
kiwi that's back there as well which is
awesome how they just love if if the
kids can manage that age group you know
chuck him in have a go
yeah that's what my dad did and i think
that's that's kind of what helped me
with the confidence in like especially
in a massive contact sport
you know i had no fear and any contact
and whatsoever and i was just throwing
myself in it
but i think probably when i took it like
mad serious is probably when
i used to go on like pre-season camps to
melbourne when i was um
at uh saint peter's college
yeah so they signed me
oh so they signed me when i was quite
young hey so i was like
16 15 16.
but during the during the days they're
saying we will sign you now so when you
turn 18 finish school you come and join
our under 20s
yeah and there was a um so that was a
competition and i was like okay sweet
i kept going and i was i kept doing
these pre-season camps and i was just
like every time i kept flying over to
melbourne i was just falling more and
more in love with it
so i ended up i think it was about 16 17
going on maybe 17.
i called
melvin storm and i was like look
i'm really keen on coming over i know
you guys got an sg ball um competition
which is the under 18s i'd like to come
and play in it and i'd like to move my
family over
like what do you reckon and uh frank
benicio at the time he stole the the ceo
there the manager there and he said mate
no dramas come around
they set me up with my me and my family
in a nice area in melbourne
and um i ended up
taking my little brother and sister out
of school
and putting them into like a you know
pretty pretty good school over in
australia
far right was there any other reason why
you wanted to get out of auckland or was
that anything to do with that or was it
purely just um the rugby side of
opportunities
no so like obviously blues and um
melbourne were
were my my two teams that i was like
keen on playing for it and then
i did meet up with someone from the
blues and obviously us for some reason
some somehow it fell through
and then the week after melbourne ended
up coming so i was just like coming in
and offering me this contract when i was
you know such a young age and i was dead
keen on just providing for my family
you know everyone loves you know giving
back to their family and their parents
and because i loved it so much i was
like i'm going to get paid for what i
love so i don't care what i'm what i
need to give my parents i don't care
they can have it all i just love playing
rugby and i can get you know i can give
back
yeah and so when they came i was it was
just a no-brainer i was like oh great
english billy slater kevin uh cameron
smith
cooper cronk bro there was all these
like superstars at melbourne and i was
just like oh i'm keen because i used to
play rugby league as well after like our
first 15 times
and so we used to play first 15 and then
first 13 as well but i used to go i used
to have to go to um like my old club at
odahu leopards
yeah we had to play there because um
we didn't st peter's in that first 13.
they only had a first 15.
so i was just like oh sweet i have to go
there and luckily my family friend was
like oh you're keen on playing i was
like look i'll give you any sport i was
doing athletics i was doing even indoor
netball outdoor netball
i was doing everything so i was like
yeah i'm keen for anything bro
man that's crazy so you were like 15 16
years old flying over to the melbourne
storm training with these absolute
legends of the sport that's buzzy
mate it was it was surreal i was going
in we i think there was about
i'd say about six of us they put us in
the hotel opposite uh where they were i
think it was princess park at the time
and um
we used to just keep walking over and
made that training was here to
it was unbelievable i think if you talk
to anyone that's experienced any like
melbourne training or even being at the
club
mate it is it is brutal
yeah
and what what were all those guys like
what would they like uh letting you come
into the environment were they all good
sorts or what did they make you work for
yeah
they're a decent brother like you know
they they they welcomed you in because
they knew we were just there for the
pre-season just to experience it with
obviously the next generation hopefully
and coming up
but they just loved it they just said as
long as you put your head down craft
then you can have a coffee with us any
day they weren't really like segregated
groups
they welcomed us in um you know i
remember billy slater giving me a first
tip on you know how to track a ball in
in the air i'll never forget that um so
yeah so it's like
right as soon as the first day i went in
i felt like i've been there for for
years so
yeah well and especially at a young age
like that it's so daunting
going with a group of like you know
grown men
probably it was they're probably like 20
25 at the time when i went but yeah
it was it was hectic i loved it
right that's crazy and were you a
fullback at the time in league
yeah yeah yeah so i was um
i was i loved fullback but i just yeah
and that's so that's when i signed for
so when i signed for melbourne melbourne
storm
they were basically like i was going to
be the next billy slater obviously that
was like a mad like reputation to try
and live up to as well yeah so every
chance i could get i was just asking
what are you doing how do you do this
what are your thoughts in these
situations
so i learned a lot when i was growing
when i was growing up and when i was in
the system for a while as well
and um
i was fortunate today because like i got
a gig so they they gave it to me because
obviously i just wanted to be around
storm i just want to be around the
players i knew i didn't want school i
just want to be around players train um
you know get as much experience as you
can but basically i used to just uh wash
the shakers
set up training pack away training
uh
give the you know the seeing as their
shakers if they're like danny i'm
missing the scoop mate i'll run around
like a madman
so i was like there like you know an
hour before training an hour after
um
packing training setting up training
doing training and i was just like but
because i loved it so much i was just
like man i don't care like i get to do
this like although it was just the work
experience basically being
being a bum boy of just like everyone at
melbourne i was just like i love it i'm
just training
was that when you signed on because you
eventually did sign in the full squad
didn't you
yeah yeah so obviously in 20s it's not a
full-time contract you you go you you
come in at like four o'clock in the
morning
you train at like five six o'clock in
the morning you go off either school
work
or whatever of course you're doing you
go off and do that and then you come
back at around like i don't know it was
4 35 again for your afternoon session
so they're saying instead of doing that
we'll have we'll put you in the work
experience we'll pay you like i think it
was like 5 000 extra dollars on top
which wasn't much but i would rather do
that than go and like dig holes for you
know the whole day and then have to go
and do some hard graft after
yeah
so yeah so
they just said yeah so let's just do
that so i was just like yeah i'm down
for that true and what was life like
doing that move you obviously come from
south auckland moving over to melbourne
with your family what was life off the
field like
mate it was crazy uh
where'd i start it was it was it was
basically like
it was it's all a blur at the minute i
like when i look back at my brother and
years flew by
uh all i remember was like the really
good stuff um just being in the large
training playing 20s
you know and then obviously getting like
an opportunity here and there but
obviously taken away because billy
slater will back up on you know play the
wednesday in queensland cup
um and then play again for melbourne on
a saturday and i was just like bloody oh
mate just take a day off
so uh you know just stuff like that i
just all i remember that and then
just
obviously going through that where that
transition period between twenties and
first grade
it was like
i didn't i didn't know where i was i was
just i got injured
um i was gutted and because i got given
everything from the start
i kind of had that silver spoon
mentality
and then i was kicking stones i was like
no i deserve this i deserve that when i
didn't deserve nothing you know i was
still
i still needed to do what i need to do
graph put my head down and wait for my
opportunity like everyone else
and you know
unfortunately for me at the time i was
young or stupid
i you know i had that mentality about me
i was like well
i've been here for so long i deserve you
know i deserve a shot
but without doing anything to be fair
and you know that's where i was at
melbourne and that's
that was that was probably the most
upsetting part probably the only bit i
regret within my career at the minute
and what was your relationship with
alcohol and
drugs not just probably in melbourne but
even before that even back in auckland
no so auckland was sweet i was just you
know just that young stupid teenager
that was sneaking off and drinking every
day every night now and then you know
everyone did it um but now it was just
like
i don't know how it come along it was
just you know
it snuck up on me
obviously it was around that period of
where i was thinking like how i was
thinking just
mad like
i was just like how can they disrespect
me like this and i was like what were
you thinking back to them like they
didn't hey they didn't disrespect me b
they didn't
i didn't like deserve nothing you know
then
and it was around that time when i was
just like well stuff this bro a lot so
alcohol came in you know girls you know
drugs
you know that recreational stuff
obviously and
none of that like hard stuff stuff but
you know what i mean so it was just like
and then it ended up becoming like
almost a vicious cycle so any time i
felt
a certain way you know upset or
disappointed and that's how i've entered
so yeah obviously
and i was under the radar i was always
injured
you know that was for the next years
coming i was always injured um i was
always in the physio room
so it was a dark time so i was just like
i just couldn't get out of that that
that
that cycle of life that i was living at
the minute and then
it was when they sat me down and was
like look like you know obviously you
need some game time against men
you know i feel like going overseas to
england for london broncos is probably
the best move for you
um
you know how about it and because i was
so young and naive i was just like you
know what like
i need to prove myself i need to do this
so yeah go on i'll have a crap
and then i ended up like um
stupidly signing it
and my agent at the time just done me
over he pulled my pants down to the max
and i was just like wow at the time
because he because obviously the english
pound an australian dollar
like at the time i think it was like
almost
almost triple or double if that yeah
so that's how he spoke to me she was
like you're gonna get around this match
this much and i was just like oh bro
that'll be sick
yeah yeah sign me up being stupid i
decided i was i think i was still 20 at
the time just turning 20. yeah
and um
obviously i was still stuck in that um
that that cycle of how i was feeling to
how i'll portray that and how i'll like
release that feeling as well
so obviously as a young 20 year old
going
halfway across the world
i didn't know what was gonna what what
was going to happen so
stupidly i signed it i jumped on that
plane
after everyone was saying you know they
advised me otherwise but i was like nah
i need to do this i need to get back
into nrl
i'm going to kill it
bro if you know and that's that's a
great thing about hindsight in it
i was like little did i know i was going
to be staying here for another couple of
years
[Laughter]
so yes i started i signed for london you
know it's 20
and what a town what a city um you know
coming from melbourne it was awesome
like it was party it was like it was
literally wouldn't sleep
so
and
that year literally playing-wise it was
probably the worst in my career ever
um
and off off
off the field like the largest suite i
had a great time with awesome chat
we had drinks every time even if we lost
we we didn't win we barely won that but
yeah then we won one game
and you know throughout that time it was
dark it was ghettos i think it was
winter
so it's getting dark at like 3 p.m
and i was just like what is going on
we're losing by 60 points it's getting
dark by 3 p.m
yeah i'm missing home i've got you know
i'm halfway around the country i've got
you know
luckily the club paid for our um our
accommodation because
you know when he was converting that
money and like it's it's all relevant to
where you are so when i moved to london
mate the prices were just through the
roof
and i was just like mate i've got i
actually can't afford to live some
months
so like it was it was crazy so like
obviously like with the losing with the
you know the bad weather
i was just in and i was just in a
massive holiday so i was just that's i
think that's where
the drinking and the drugs started
amplifying because
that's where i was at it's dark as we
were losing
and then
i ended up trying to get back over to
melbourne and they ended up saying no
sorry mate like this isn't that this is
not a gig here for you anymore
so i was just like what
this is crazy still i ended up like
breaking down a lot just because i was
like my family's there like i've got
nowhere else to go the transfer window
is gone as well for nrl so there was
literally no
way possible for me to even get back
home
so i ended up just
sacking that uh australian agent that i
had at the time
yeah and signing with someone from
england
hoped like just in that hopes just to
get me one more year just to give me a
good team so i could play my way back to
australia or back to new zealand
and then signed for castleford and you
know
and the first year mate was also awesome
it was good it was good you know the
fans were awesome you know the stadium
was packed every single game yeah we
were winning reasonably like you know
the ratio to winning and losing was as a
normal team so i was like oh this is
this is a lot better i can deal with
this
so like but the weather still wasn't
that great
and luckily like i ended up going back
home from my 21st before i went to to
cast went back to england
yeah and that was tough because
obviously i missed home i just wanted to
stay and stay in melbourne
so yeah then i ended up signing for
castleford the the year after
and for castleford mate on the field you
were on absolute fire scored all sorts
of tries from everywhere i think you
broke the record for most tries in a
season i think you were even
in the frame for man of steel or the
biggest accolade there is over there so
matt your form on the field was on fire
but um off the field were you still up
to the same
um things off the field
yeah mate and it was just like it was
crazy because it it started off but it
started off as just like an outlet of
you know of my emotions of how i dealt
with it
but then yeah
it was just this growing like feeling
and i didn't i didn't understand what it
was
and
i was like like you said i i you know
the season of my life and but as soon as
i left the field see as soon as i left
the training ground
it's just a sense of emptiness if that
makes sense i just
other than being a rugby player i didn't
know who i was or what i was going to do
or what i was even about
and that's what i struggled with like
like my identity off
the pitch
obviously everyone knew me as the rugby
player and that was kind of it and
that's all i knew i was
and that's kind of like probably the the
underlying feeling of what where it came
from is i didn't understand
how to
um
just basically all and be in order of my
life so i didn't understand how to like
separate being a rugby player
to just being a normal guy that's out in
the street
or having a conversation there was
literally no separation it was either
rugby or nothing and i because i didn't
have rugby
out after rugby i didn't know who i was
so i had nothing all i had was alcohol
and drugs what did a normal week sort of
look like for you were you on the piss
all the time were you doing drugs all
the time or was it just sort of after a
game
yes so bro i was just i was just on the
piss all the time so i have like couple
like at least three bottles of of you
know of wine or red
on a wednesday we'll play on a
friday it was like so i wake up hungover
i'll go to captain's run we'll do
captains run
i'll sleep all day just wake up i'll
make sure i swing it you know a bottle
or two of water before i go and play and
then i'll go and play like that yeah and
that's how it was kind of like it was
going
so yeah it was it was hectic on the
field and it was it was hectic off the
field
so were you living by yourself or you
going out with mates to drink these
bottles of wine or um do your drinks
i was just at home i was just well yeah
just playing
i'll play some music
obviously and then just
one bottle will lead to the next the
next will lead to the other one and then
i'll have one in like in the cupboard
that i hide away i mean i end up finding
that one
and it was obviously looking back at it
it was it was dark bro it's like
obviously i'd and that's probably why i
do what i do now um with all this whole
mental health um
situations and campaigns that you know i
offer myself to
because
i did it all alone and you know when i
didn't need to and i felt
i isolated myself as well and i
alienated everyone around me because i
didn't i that's i didn't know how to
express my feelings i didn't know
how to deal with the the fact of
you know
i i didn't know who i was i didn't know
who i was when i left the field
and instead of obviously like chatting
to someone
about this this whole feeling i just
ended up drowning myself and i'm digging
myself a bigger hole every time
did any of your teammates know that you
were
in this sort of situation or they
wouldn't have known because you're doing
it all by yourself
they would not know because i was doing
it all myself yeah bro
but then there was a one time where we
went out and like um
i said in every you know every interview
or podcast i do
so it wasn't for if it wasn't for my
best mate michael channing at the time
he we basically went out i took um
ketamine so i did horse tranquilizer
like liquid form and i thought i was
like and i was just like i was just i
think it was almost at the end of the
season so i was coming up to like
obviously you know big games big
decisions on like man of steel
um you know
i was coming up to breaking the
tri-scoring record like i think it was a
few weeks after
and i just thought [ __ ] i can't i can't
deal with this head noise anymore
like um
it's too much for me
so i ended up taking it and
i got up to all sorts i was trying to
fight police officers
i think i ended up doing something
stupid
passing out my best mate took me home
back to his and his his partner's house
at the time
back in leeds
and waking up in the morning so they
stayed up all night looking after me but
they thought i wasn't breathing at times
so they stayed awake looking after me
and the morning after
i woke up
like an absolute helmet and was hey guys
how's it going good morning
and mate they weren't happy at all like
and obviously like best mates like you
expect this kind of chat to come from
and you know and i'm very fortunate for
him and i'm very thankful
to to mike for this and you know him and
his missus uh said look mate but last
night was scary we had to stay up for
you
you weren't breathing at some at some
point in the night
there's something wrong bro you've got
to sort yourself out because this isn't
the first time this has just been the
worst time
but this isn't the first time
so i ended up saying yeah [ __ ] like you
know i'm sorry that shouldn't have
happened
the first couple of days i was in
denials right now they're just they're
just chatting rubbish and i'm i'm not
like i don't need to see someone
yeah and then it was probably like back
into the week where i was getting a bit
nervous for the game
the game happened
then it was back to that that that
feeling that head noise
so i was just like nah yeah they're
right something's not something he's got
to give
and i ended up seeing someone from
sporting chance which helps uh super
league which helped super league at the
time they're like a like a sports like a
players union's
a place where you can go and seek help
yeah
so that was so that's that's kind of was
a stepping stone towards it to help me
identify what was going on
and then
that year i ended up
signing for sale
because obviously me and
me and the coach
had a bit of words obviously you know
things happen with disagreements happen
and you know i ended up signing signing
over at sale
so obviously that kind of
was put on the back burners like my
whole
trying to identify who i was as a man or
as a person kind of got put on back on
the back burner because
the the scrutiny i got the the social
media hate
you know everything about the move
was it was just like it was just mad
crazy i just didn't understand where to
where to look
and luckily for say like lucky for me
sale ended up saying danny just
don't even look at your phone
we'll handle like all the legal
processes like you do what you need to
do you just jump on that field and score
some tries
so i was like yeah sweet i'm good at
that
and then like it was crazy because i i
was like yeah sweet i'm just good at
playing i just block out the head noise
block out the fan so i kind of put
myself
and everything about me
apart from playing rugby
and on the back burner
for that first year and then
like
funny enough like when i did it i was
playing some like awesome rugby
i ended up having a chat with eddie
jones and he was like look mate what
what's your what's your plans you've
been here coming this year
you've been here for five years and
that's your eligible um your the
eligibility rule is you to be here for
five years you can play for england
and i was like
so i look back at what i've achieved
what i've done
i was like
you know what i don't feel like i want
to leave now anyway
i feel like england's given me so much
like
maybe this is a way to give back as well
and then you know financially find the
financial gains from playing for england
as well
also helped
you know i'm not going to lie you know
it gave a good question and obviously
you know coming from you know
a guy from south auckland that's you
know got nothing
if you throw that at him you're just
like yes sweet but
give it to me bro
what were you like with your money going
through the whole sort of grades
to be fair some parts i was good
sometimes i was bad um i ended up
investing in property
yeah so obviously that was like the good
thing about it
but then i could have invested in a lot
more and i ended up just splurging it
mainly splurging it yeah probably like
so when i
played for england i ended up trying to
buy a house in in the local area to sail
so i ended up buying that house putting
some money into that
so that that was the main of it of of
where i spent most of my money but
i was still young i was only like 23 i
think at the time
23 or 24 so like and i was getting all
this money i was just spending like
crazy i was just
doing stupid things going out for dinner
going out for like expensive nights out
and so like
that that sort of stuff on that that
front kept happening
and
obviously that was just it
it came to a point where i think i got
kicked out of england england camp for
drinking with manu
uh true talk to me about this one how
did this
did you lead him astray or
yeah nah i think it was like you know
i'm old man i made my own decision and
so was it so we we ended up just
drinking
obviously you know
coach was like yeah sweet i have the
night off lads like you know
enjoy yourselves but he didn't you
probably didn't mean go out to you know
out into london central and enjoy
yourself
[Laughter]
so like you know that obviously looking
back at it like i was still only very
young i was 24 i think
and
i was just like mate i'm like
nothing's wrong in my life at the minute
i'm playing awesome rugby i'm you know
i've represented england
um you know i've got the life of my
dreams there like i'm and i was on cloud
nine
and obviously it came crashing down when
you know
when he kicked us off the women when he
kicked us both out of the squad
and it was kind of like a learning curve
of just like maybe you can't keep taking
a piss like how many lives do you want
um
so
i knew
drinking was a problem so
however like stressed or head noise i
had
drink was always the way i went about it
yeah and you know like and i think
that was probably the main thing of just
trying to
get a different perspective on how to
deal with these emotions and how to
release them
and it wasn't probably till the
following year where i was going through
a divorce
and
it was kind of like i was just like
back and forth like with all these
emotions and it was this guy ollie from
saviorworld on my instagram
and james o'connor was um was in it as
well
and he was like look bro just come along
like i understand you know you're
pulling you pull you're trying to pull
against this this this gravity that's
pulling you towards this movement like
this is going to be good for you you
need this and i was like nah bro like
can't be asked like that's too much
it's too out there for me i i'm more of
just i'll just deal with it myself kind
of thing
and he was like bro you know what suit
yourself like
you know you can take the the horse to
water but you can't make him drink yeah
so i was just like yes all right that's
sweet bro
and probably when i was going through
that divorce and it was like that period
where i needed to make that decision
whether i was going to be in the
marriage or not
and i made that decision to not be in
that marriage anymore
so i broke up
you know we had a divorce
mate and then probably the day after i
hit him up and i was like hey mate like
you know my name's danny
you know james o'connor you know
introduced us a few day a few weeks
about do you mind if we come and have a
chat
and bro i feel like that changed my life
so
because it was just
it was just teaching me how to be
me
without forcing me to to do anything
else if that makes sense so he's being
more of my subconscious
and
saying do you really need to do that or
do you
feel like this is the right thing for
you at the time
and if i'm honest he did a lot of
digging we did a lot of soul searching
we did a lot of like grounding
and
i've done i've not done that much crying
ever in my life
yeah i feel like a lot of trauma
built over over the years
came out obviously it's going through
you know the marriage uh england
pressure the pressure of you know coming
into sale after an awesome year so
just just everything in general kind of
just got on top of me and i didn't know
how else other to release it than drugs
and alcohol
and you know unfortunately enough for
rugby union they're quite strict so
them drugs are probably like you know
prescriptive drugs so you know sleepers
and all that sort of stuff
and you know ollie was just like mate
like get a grip bro like you either have
a look at yourself and
look at yourself in the mirror and say
what do you want to do with your life
how you want to live it
or you succumb to this feeling and you
you allow it to dominate you for the
rest of your life
and so he gave me tools and ways to you
know
dictate that feeling um understand it
more and
and when i do feel it which is awesome
at the minute like i have ways and means
to deal with it other than alcohol now
yeah and you know especially my little
family it was so important and
it was funny like it was crazy how it
all worked out like when
when me and ollie ended up you know
parting ways because it was just like
well i've got nothing more to teach you
i feel like i'm leaving you at the best
place that i've i can see you in
and then
i ended up meeting my partner so i was
just like
bloody like this couldn't like you can't
make it up
yeah and you know
and it was awesome i think for her as
well just like
for me to understand my own feelings my
own emotions
and
you know so that she we're on the same
page every time i'm feeling a certain
way
so yeah that it's been awesome
so what are what are those ways that you
use now instead of going to the drink or
to drugs because i mean there's a lot of
guys out there who'll be feeling those
same sort of things or turning to the
bottle still so what have you got any
sort of tips or anything you could
recommend for some of these guys
oh bro as simple as it sounds like
breathing helped
like sitting yourself in a calm room
like people call it meditating people
call it yoga
you know
anything's that sorts of like you have
to control your breathing focus on your
breathing more
it it helped me so like i had two dogs
at the time and i loved walking because
i loved walking and we used to take them
on hikes
so getting out in fresh air having that
walk in the morning to to release that
that stimulant in your in your mind and
your brain that gives you them good um
hormones i think it's called endorphins
i think it is
yeah so if you release them quite early
like it's almost like i think that quote
is when the morning you win the day
so if you can do something that
um benefits you and puts your mind in
the right track
you know it'll it'll go a long way so i
think like i used to well before i had
my partner i used to be in a like a
really strict regime
obviously wake up make my bed
go down feed my dogs we'll go out come
back let him out
let him back in get changed for training
then i'll go so that's that was my
morning it was every morning and if i
did anything out of sorts it'll send me
nuts say i'll just feel like i'll be all
over the place
obviously like having a child now is it
kind of puts it all into like into
shambles really so you can't really have
a set time
but
you know
i just looking back and looking back on
my life and my career although it was
all in the spotlight
when it when when i wasn't in the
spotlight when i was in in my home and
behind back closed doors
them dark times still i grew from that
and i look i learned from it and it
taught me a lot
and
that's probably why i do like i said
like how i helped out with um
mental health campaigns just to just get
put my message out there just to make
obviously like you said every every it
can happen to anyone but you know
you can be a guy that works nine to five
you can be a sports athlete like me
depression and you know anxiety and all
these things don't they don't
care who you are
yeah they're just like hey bro
nice it's nice to meet you
oh mate you're doing awesome awesome
work in that space and i know a lot of
people be getting a lot of stuff out of
it especially this one in particular but
one thing that sort of stands out for me
throughout your career is how you still
manage to be
so good on the field with what you're
doing off it like um you obviously
weren't doing much as as much training
as some um you were straight onto the
drink and straight into your drugs your
recovery and stuff probably wasn't that
good but when you got on the field mate
you were you were just next level like
you would still rip it up even though
you were sort of
professional but didn't have that
professional mindset
yeah well
it's funny uh
i had it when i crossed the line
i was everything
an athlete needs to be when i cross that
line and i say i'd even i even joke
about it now i'm like i even tell my
missus and my because when i first met
my missus she was like oh do you need to
be on this do you need to do that and i
was just like look love like
i'm the worst athlete you're ever going
to meet
i said i don't do diets you know i don't
do like your conventional like you know
i need to go
a sauna i needed a spa
i need a massage here and there like
i'm i'm chilled bro like as long as i'm
good and i feel good
i i don't care
you know i mean i'm surrounded by my
family that loves me i'm loving myself
more and more every day and as i am with
my family just loving it more and more
every day
it's just awesome and i know
i've got i've still got
a lot left in me
and i know that like i said in my
interview in the new zealand herald that
that the itch on my back i know it's i
know it's
in new zealand and
speaking to my missus just recently
she's like
you've done probably a lot in
australia and england every country
you've gone to
and i said but you started at new
zealand so
and because you didn't do much there
other than playing first 15 play and all
these sports when you're at school
you haven't really
gone back and played any rugby there
and i was like yeah and she and i was
just chatting to him i was like yeah but
there's obviously the money-wise you
know i don't want to leave us
like sure i want to make sure that we
live life to the full as well and
she's like danny like
money is just money
we can go there experiences you can't
get back you can't
physically pay to get an experience back
and
i was just like far out yeah you're
right like
i would probably regret it if i didn't
do this
now if that makes sense
yeah and obviously i'm still
i'm still probably at a pretty decent
age to go back and you know play some
decent footing you're in your prime and
i know
and i know uh brent evans has gone back
to highlanders he's killing it
i think he's about
i think he's about 35 bro
oh mate nah definitely not too late oh
that's exciting times
um also
something else that happened in your
career you've sort of spoken about it
that was your divorce and i know it was
sort of a high-profile relationship um
i'm not sure how your ex became famous
but i've seen lots of photos of you guys
walking the catwalks and living the very
glamorous life what was what was that
relationship like and how did that one
come about
oh mate
i've never really said it on on air or
you know in an interview before
but
because i was so young i met her at the
time where i when i struggled the most
yeah i think i'm mistaken
gratitude
for love
and
obviously
you know she came at the time where i
probably needed someone to come in
and
and intercept whatever was happening at
that time in my life
yeah so yeah so i think you know
at the time i was just more grateful and
you know we did hit it off like we you
know we had a lot in common we had you
know
like everyone does but i think the
overriding feeling that was going in
that relationship was more grateful
and i because i didn't even know how to
portray my feelings or even understand
my own
so i didn't understand the difference
between grateful and love
and obviously later down in the line
you know that
that gratitude ended up sliding you know
i was just like well i it ended up being
thrown back in my face at times because
obviously she came at the time she did
and i wasn't
going to sit there and allow
it to be thrown back in my face just
because you know
some people come in your life for a
reason and some you know and they leave
and you know unfortunately enough
you know it was it was a lesson
learned on my part
to really get stuck into to identifying
how i feel and that's one thing i did
work a lot with ollie
before meeting my partner because i
didn't want to make that mistake again
i wanted to
to understand
the differences of how i feel and when i
feel it and
what scenarios it's going to come to be
prepared
because you know
you never know what's going to happen
you know life's life throws you
curveballs every chance it gets
so like
i just wanted to be as prepared as i
could if i was to get into another
relationship
it wouldn't
be
the same if that makes sense i would
understand myself more
to then
give her more of a chance to be loved
and me receive it as well
and i was just so self-destructive at
the time as well i just
any chance i could get i'll just be like
oh boom i'm gonna throw the bomb i'll
just detonate it
so i was just i'll just all every shop
said like yeah so
it's the first time that i've said it
that i was i
you know
and i'm
it's sad to say that i at the time was
grateful
rather than rather than love
yeah and did the the whole publicity
around the relationship make it way more
harder did you enjoy that side of things
so the cameras the articles all that
sort of
bro at the time i'm not gonna lie that i
loved it you know i was like i'm in a
paper for something other than
rugby
so yeah i loved it and because like i
said i struggled with that identity
thing so i got caught up in that
lifestyle
so then
you know that and that was the whole
kind of snowball where
it just it just kept on going and then
obviously things where things happen
like she had to pretend that she was
single for shows
um
and obviously because my mental state
wasn't as as tough as
you know most people
probably wouldn't even allow it
in the first place i just let it go you
know i mean i was just like [ __ ]
but you know what i mean so i was just i
was just going on for the ride
and then what do you mean she had to be
um she had the single when she was like
what sort of shows are those
so she did x on the beach in that so
like do you know them single um reality
shows
and was she with you at the time yeah
she was with me at the time and then she
did a
big brother as well
celebrity big brother
and mate even even some of the sailors
like
the week that was going on
made my anxiety levels bro i was just
all over the shop
and like
one day in training i took two too many
diazies
and i was training like an absolute [ __ ]
so i was just like
i don't know where i am
and um
just
you know luckily all the boys had my
back they're just like bro just go in
that but have a rest like we'll tell
them you you know you're sick
you need to go home and and sleep it off
and yes it's like
it cost me a lot that relationship but
it
it made me realize a lot as well it
taught me a lot bro like yeah just from
everything about that and
obviously i've still got a lot to learn
still i still you know no man's perfect
no woman's perfect
our relationships go through you know
highs and lows still
but you know it was it's a lot better
than what i used to be doing
so
yeah and i you know i can look back and
be proud of myself of where i've come
from
and another thing that teaches you
things pretty quickly is children i know
from experience but
how have you found being a dad
bro i love it i hate like yeah just
everything about it bro just like she
puts a smile on my face every time i
like think of her
um she's just coming like i reckon she's
hitting terrible twos at early a because
her attitude well and i was like nah
not now we've got like an 18-hour flight
on our second hall
i was like i can't be dealing with this
this attitude this
this indecisiveness i was like i can't
be dealing with this
and how long's your miq is that two
weeks still
uh 10 days yeah 14. i land on the the
fifth you get out on the 15th
and may it's been stressful lately i've
been just trying to find a house i'm
still trying to find a place to rent
back home
so it's just been it's just been
mentally
specialized
bro
i know are you selling up your place
over in england or you keep there
yeah we're keeping it we're renting it
out
um so
sorry we just got news uh my my partner
and my daughter's visas got approved
yes
sorry
she's just
yeah she's just come through she's like
it's been approved oh yeah sorry guys
that's awesome no worries
i told you why not
we decided
well just by the time we got into new
zealand
yeah because she's been mad stressed
about this lately and i think yeah fair
enough
and going back to like you know our
mindset about what we do in our lives is
just about just
believing in that hey like 100 and i
felt like this whole week
everything kind of fell into place so
obviously our tenants for our property
here now in that in our house here
they're coming in and they're wanting to
move in as the day after we leave the
house
and
obviously just then our visas just come
through approved
um before
i just sold my one of my properties here
in um
in england here as well to find out
obviously the visas just to make sure
that new zealand know they're only here
for a holiday
yeah and we've got enough fun so we had
to sell up i was because i was already
selling anyway and then i was oh well we
can look at a house over there and try
and buy it but i ended up finding out
you need 20 deposits
who has 20
on like a average house there's probably
like 2 million i'm like who the hell has
20 percent of 2 million dollars
like you've got to be out of your mind
crazy hey what is it over there
well average
you can get a three bed terrace for like
i reckon two 250 300 000.
and what's up what's that so that's like
oh five so if you if you're a first home
buyer five percent because then the
government puts five percent so that's
that scheme
and then generally it's like ten percent
yeah
right twenty percent welcome to new
zealand
i was like proper confident hey i was
like bro i've got this much coming and
you know i'm you know i'm selling my
house you know this is what's going on
i've got rent behind me as well so
what's what's the crap they're like yeah
you need 20 i was just like no
i was like mate
what so what is your plans are you are
you going to stay in new zealand long
term do you see yourself finishing here
moving here back for good or you haven't
got that far
no i haven't got that far right you know
i'm just going as far as landing in new
zealand bro but
uh you know i've got like i need to sort
out obviously like an accommodation to
stay in when we leave when we get out
there 15th but i still haven't like
figured that out it's the 24th of jan we
leave on the third or feb
so like i'm cutting it a bit short here
but like i said to my wishes i was like
when i first made the decision to
obviously sign and go to speak
to to say all about this decision that
i'm about to make
i just i sat her down and i was just
like look i need 100
i don't want even one percent doubt or
99 behind me so if we make this decision
as a family as as a couple right now
we need 100 so i need i need all in i
don't want no chips being hidden i need
you know all guns blazing you know
everything in it she was like i've got
you we've got this and i was like as
long as i got you behind my back when
i'm going to make this decision
i know everything's going gonna happen
and i've always had that mentality
anyway so i'll go and
give everything i've got
and
fortunate for us like like i just said
everything just this last maybe a week
everything's fallen into place for us to
come back home to new zealand
and may and that's probably why i'm so
excited like talking to you as well it's
just like
mate i've not heard
anyone back over new zealand or
australia in a long time so hearings
like homegrown accents yeah i love it
yeah what accent have you got that's
sort of half half bro it's a hybrid
it was a bit like my mental state it
looks like
[Laughter]
oh mate it's exciting time so man i
can't wait to
see you out there in a super rugby team
playing some super rug it's going to be
awesome but mate anyway before we
uh as always we've gone to our instagram
for some questions and mate lots of
people have come in for you
lots of good stuff so we'll get through
them
uh first question is it true that at the
storm you were faster than billy slater
a hundred percent mate 100
yeah yeah
he was mate he was just like quick
so he was agile just sniffing obviously
top end speed yeah oh i got billy
see you later
okay who's your favorite player to watch
in super rugby and why
super rugby
bro i've got two a and it you know
they're
they're crazy like they're glitchy polar
opposites but
um
arty salvia at the minute just as like
just as
this dynamics of how we how he plays
rugby um
and just the way he he thinks and as a
captain as well like
just the maturity of his of his rugby
and probably the the other exciting one
was um caleb clark
yeah yeah
bro he is a beast
and obviously like having roger there
now with him i i'm looking forward to
roger and if i get to play with or
against i'm just going to be admiring a
pair of them
yeah but obviously everyone knows you
know that
did you grow up with roger did you play
against roger as a young fellow one of
those questions came in
yeah we went to the same school together
we went to odu college so i went to
college first as a local public school
and obviously i got a scholar a
scholarship to go and play for saint
peter's at the time as well so i ended
up leaving college and going to saint
peter's and we played against them for
first 15. uh and roger was playing full
back at his time and i was playing uh 13
at the time
excuse me
sure how do you reckon he's gonna go on
rugby
hey he's he's a natural athlete he's he
kills it i feel like
regardless of where i know i've read
that he wants to play 12 and i think
that's a perfect position for him he you
know he's come from a league background
as well
so like
have that physicality about him you know
he wants it he greets it
he's played full back so his skill set's
going to be there
you know and
i think he's just got the all-round game
i think if you're a blues fan you're
going to be excited
right and they might potentially add you
on the wing do you see yourself as a
pure pure winger or
do you see yourself playing potentially
midfield could you play anywhere else
bro you see i've had this argument for a
lot of people that
the only reason why i played wing is
because when you're in like first grade
or when you're playing league if you're
a young
back player coming to play
you play wing first yeah and it's just
unfortunate for me that i ended up
playing very well and i just had to be
stuck there
but no i would like to play anywhere bro
like if it's the wing that they need me
if then i'll play wing if it's
you know i'm a utility i want to play
all sorts of positions and i want to
impact the game just as much as the next
bloke
and i feel like i've got a lot more to
offer coming back home with a lot of
experience behind my you know under my
belt
and that's what i'm trying to come back
and bring home to you know to new
zealand rugby
no i can't wait i got lots of questions
about this one what mpc team would you
like to play for lots of people ask me
if you'd come to the southland stags
bro i've seen that eh
they're throwing up the stags up there i
think uh ben boyle as well he's he's
he's a local lad from there as well oh
true
so um uh to be fair bro like i'm not
as long as it's you know it's the right
kind of game style you know play style
for myself because i wanna i wanna i
wanna play some expansive rugby i
haven't played expensive rugby in years
and obviously i would like to get back
to you know throwing the ball around
with no no pressure that i'm gonna get
dropped the next week
so like any obviously i'm gonna have to
go do do my homework now just figure out
what team kind of i want to slot into
not i want to mold
to me
i want to go in they've already got that
kind of
that game style that you know that
coach's philosophy and i want to just
slot in and look like i've been there
for years so that's what i want to do
bro
mate you sound the perfect fit for the
tasman marco actually
[Laughter]
okay next question best eddie jones
story
oh mate
i've got too many
but
there's obviously um
there's there's this one time we're in
argentina camp and one of the boys are
well known for
obviously getting up to no good
and um
he was he put him in basically put him
in hotel prison
so
he wouldn't you wouldn't allow him out i
can't tell you the name because you know
it's it's a bit private
yeah literally
no child i i wish he did
it probably would have made it easier i
wouldn't have got kicked out
but uh you know he put him in basically
put him in house arrest so he would just
only be allowed to come and eat
come for the meetings
go to train anything else he was back in
his room
i was like bro
are you sure so he and he he was dead
serious as well and you put him up at
that front because you always fall
asleep in meetings
so you'll be like right at the front
right near eddie and he'll always put
him and he'll always from banter as well
so it was quite funny but that's like my
my biggest one that i i tell everyone
like watch eddie like yeah he just loves
rugby bro he loves taking the piss out
of everyone he loves having a laugh
what was he like with you what we what
was he like to hear
his heels decent but to be very young
he got to know me quite fast he kind of
understood what i was about
obviously my family was was my biggest
you know motivator
and obviously he just said look like
what would you do if you know your
family was was doing this doing that
how would you react would your energy
levels be this do that he was almost
like a psychologist in there
he loves mind games as well so whether
he was trying to play mind games and i
just thought he was being a nice dude
i don't know
but
he i feel i think he was these i i think
he was these i learned a lot from him
because i think
my favorite story of him is
he used to watch like russian rugby like
or like some rugby could be played
somewhere in the world that no one knows
of
he finds that game and he likes watching
it just to find that probably that one
thing he might be interested in just to
bring in
he loves rugby and i i i kind of like
enjoyed how much
he liked rugby or he loved rugby and it
taught me a lot
um no that's cool
okay next question got a lot of ones
like this from obviously you're a big
deal over in sale got lots of fans over
there
most of them just wanted to know how did
you find your time at sale
oh bro
i think that's this is where all my my
fondest memories of england have come
from
um
the day day one i got there
i was expecting their like sales fans to
hate me for for you know for obviously
obvious reasons
um made that hope they welcome you with
open arms
uh i think the first lap i did
i
took photos they're just expressing how
much they enjoyed watching me even in
rugby league they said look i'm i'm both
i love both codes i love watching you in
league and now i get to watch you live
here for sale the club they love
and just the love and passion that they
had for the club like we're we're a team
dominated by football and
you know to have
you know
manchester born and bred play uh
fans come to watch us other than you
know man united and man city football it
was awesome and just to get just to
understand their passion and their love
for sale as a club
it kind of made me want to do
and play a bit more for them
and i remember playing against sail one
night and mate i've still got your
shoulder imprinted on my ribs
oh the spot tackle from you mate i'll
have to try and dig up that footage it's
still
still sore when i look down at it oh bro
honestly i like because because i'm said
like i i don't like being a grub on the
field but i just like love the contact
day because yeah because coming from
rugby league we i had no contact so i
was like any chance i could get i would
just try and like
either run straight into someone or just
tackle someone said bro i don't think
you did i think you and janine
yes
okay next question this is this could go
anywhere this one what is your biggest
bender this sounds
sounds like it's been the last eight
years but
who's who's asked
yeah
eight years
my life's blue
[Laughter]
okay next one who was your best roomie
sam james
uh bro swear down sam james bro
i remember so it was my first year up
until probably only last year that i
that i've never had him as a roomie
mate decent dude decent crack
we'd always watch a film
we'd always sit there we'll have like i
think we'll have like a packet of
chocolate and a packet of sweets each
we'll sit there and just chat about the
film
i it just everything about sam james but
i just loved him a he's a great dude
often on the pitch um
the skill set he had
right and he was down down right the
best room because i love gaming as well
so he'll just let the game like
he'll just let me game all night
he won't even budge
i think we only had one
disagreement is when i i think we're in
um
in spain and i think i snored the house
down
he ended up waking up at like six
o'clock in the morning going to the
beach to sleep on the beach and one of
the sun beds there and his missiles he
ends up texting me like danny you better
wake up now and let sam james back in
the room and stop snoring and i was just
like oh bro i'm so sorry
that was probably the only disagreement
we've ever had whilst rooming together
oh well that's good stuff
okay next question would you play for
samoa this one came up a few times
obviously you played for samoa in rugby
league which we didn't even really get
to touch on played england
and union so
i think that
how many how many years ago was it that
you played for england
i think it's been three i think three or
four years
so one or two more years and then you're
eligible to play for summer
no no no
is it five years is it i think it i
think it's five could be wrong has it
been five years since i've played for
england well they're i'm i'm eligible
now
oh you're eligible oh you can play yeah
yeah oh true
yeah
it is it is like
probably
it wasn't
the decisive move of why i wanted to
come back to new zealand like i said it
was for my family and obviously
conveniently enough like the decision
got overturned when i made the decision
um
like i said in my new zealand herald
interview i just if it happens it
happens all i want to do is focus on
going back playing some some good footie
and like i said i'm just because i
played for england doesn't mean you know
the coach for someone was going to just
turn around said yeah you're going to be
like automatically in yeah you know if
i'm playing some good rugby and he ends
up calling my name yeah why not you know
no one
it's very rare for anyone to experience
a world cup
and
i would love for that to happen
especially at the end of my career as
well
and it will be awesome i think it would
be a great experience for me and it'll
be a great like you know tick of the box
of of my career and what i've done so
far
mate yeah that's an awesome carrot to be
at the end of the day at world cup over
in france playing for someone
and the team will be really
stacked now with this real change won't
it there's so many guys that become
available added to the guys they've
already got and it's going to be a real
strong side yeah i feel that way every
every nation i think that's that's the
most exciting thing like every nation
is going to be uh it probably we won't
you know obviously back into the the
you know the game maybe you know england
new zealand aussie france you know they
might sneak it
they might you know end up
having momentum
but it's just the fact of having
possibly an even ground to start on
i feel like that's the most exciting
thing for for everyone that represents
that
you know enjoys you know the island
rugby and i know a lot of islanders have
have pulled through and you know that
could be potentially coming back which
is this is very exciting
yeah mate looking forward to that
how good okay last question
best piece of advice you've ever
received and
mate going from this podcast sounds like
you've got a lot
oh bro
it's too many
but the biggest one
i think
for me
myself how i took it is
just to love yourself be patient with
yourself
um you know you're you're going to be
your own worst
um critic as well
so you need to take time to love
yourself take care of yourself be
patient
you know we're all human
that's how i took it um obviously i i
put myself through the ringer you know i
doubted myself
and everyone's going to
i feel like you need to you know believe
in yourself that you can do it
and you know like i said love yourself i
feel like that's probably my biggest one
there's multiple ways in doing so bro
like just small ways taking yourself for
a walk
doing something that's good for your
soul bro that's that's like what how i
took it
for me it was enjoying a nice cup of
coffee after a dog walk
you know that's that was mine
love that love that mate
so good so much good stuff in that
podcast mate really appreciate you
coming on and being so open and honest
about your career today because
obviously it's been a very eventful one
you've had your highs you've had your
lows but um like we've talked about
already i'm super excited to see you on
this side of the world with your family
all settled in and playing some unreal
super rugby and hopefully on the
international stage with sama
nah but i appreciate you having me bro
thank you very much it's a privilege er
thank you very much
mate you're a lad appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely you